-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actress
and comedian you know from
"Saturday Night Live,"
which is back this weekend
with host Keegan-Michael Key
and musical guest
Olivia Rodrigo.
The third and final season
of her show "Shrill"
is streaming now on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-I was talking to my buddy Will,
alright?
I have known him for
a really long time,
since high school.
He works at the science museum
He is perfect, and I realize
that you two are probably
perfect for one another.
-Wow. You said we're perfect for
each other, like, three times.
-That's perfect.
-Oh, my God.
Okay, well,
then give him my number
and tell him
to text my dumb ass.
-I will do that.
-Ooh, God.
I'm juggling
a lot of nasty boys.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Aidy Bryant.
[ Applause ]
Hello!
-Hi!
Oh, thank you, my friend.
Wow.
-Hi, Aidy.
-Hi!
-It's lovely to see you.
-Oh, it's nice to be
in a room with you.
-You had quite a weekend.
-Yeah.
-Friday, "Shrill" came out
-Yep.
-Birthday?
-Uh-huh.
-Happy birthday, Aidy.
-Thank you.
-And then on Saturday,
you had a live show.
-Yeah, I would say
it was so much attention
that now I'm ruined
and I'll never be the same
-Yeah.
-Like, now, do you just feel
the lack of attention
in these moments?
-Yeah, I'm devastated
even right here.
I need more. Where the hell --
I'm, like, freaking out.
-You got to,
which is very sweet --
your mom was on the show,
as were all
the cast members' mothers.
That's the third time
your mom's been on the show.
-She's an old pro, and she's
being mean about it now.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-How does the meanness
sort of show itself?
-You know, I mean,
she's just like kind of
cruising around the studio
like, "Excuse me."
And also, we had, like,
a prop that was in it,
a dress that then was cut,
and they hadn't Eamon,
our prop guy, know yet.
And so, like,
he came to hand it to her.
And before I could be like
"Oh, it's cut."
She was like,
"That's scratched."
Which I was like, "Scratched?"
That's not an industry term,
ma'am.
I loved it, though. She wa
like, "That's scratched."
I was like, "Damn."
-I can't believe, by the way
I was on that show
for twelve and a half years,
and not one Mother's Day
in the entire time I was there
-Well, then
what is happening to me?
-I think -- oh, yeah,
'cause once is awesome.
Is that what you're very
secretly saying, is one time
-I think once
would have been nice.
Three is now like,
"Well, here we go again."
-She's like, "I remember
when I got my Taft-Hartley."
-I know.
She's a full SAG member.
-Did you have any time
to celebrate
your birthday on Friday?
I know it's very hard
on the show.
-Not a moment. Devastating
-Yeah.
-No, no, I mean, you know,
my mom was in town,
which was really nice, and, yo
know, we hung out a little bit
But it's a worker's time,
so it's fine.
-Congratulations on "Shrill.
-Thanks.
-Three seasons.
-Yeah.
-And this season, of course,
the challenge that many show
had this year
of COVID protocols.
-Yeah.
-Is this a dressing room?
What is this area here?
-No.
This is a little box that
we would go in between setups.
And I don't know that
it made us safer,
but it certainly was
a demented feeling.
-Yeah.
-So like, between setups,
we would go in these little,
like, shower curtain boxes
-'Cause it seems
like there's a lot of places
that the COVID could get in.
-I think the air could
come in the top, the front
the back, the side.
-And COVID famously
uses the air as passage.
-That's what we're hearing
But yeah, no, I mean, there were
all kinds of different things.
Also, you know, like,
normally we have stand-ins
which we still did,
but we also have, like,
intimate scenes on the show,
you know?
And so they didn't want
to have to make our stand-ins,
like, get on top of each other
So they started using -- I think
you have a picture of it.
-Yeah, so this is...
would you call this
a hyper-realistic dummy?
-I would, and I think
it's important to know
that's me.
-So this is --
I mean, of course,
I had to be told it was a dummy,
because I assumed this was
a photo of you on a bed.
-Yeah, of course.
-What a good job they did.
-So that's for a sex scene
That represents me.
-And you, famously, during sex
your arm gets
quadruple-jointed.
-That's right,
and my knees are together,
but my feet go out.
I make them work for it.
-The feet out let you know
like, "I'm interested,"
and then knees together.
-I'm open-minded.
Work your way up.
But I do think it's cool
because then, you know,
sometimes they would have
sort of the male stand-in
get on top and have, like,
an intimate moment.
-This looks like the thumbnail
of a bunch of Netflix shows.
Like, a Netflix documentary.
-I mean, can't you
feel the intimacy?
-Yeah.
-It's beautiful, I think.
-It's really beautiful.
-My hair looks good.
-I also, like, for me,
I find it's, um --
I like to have,
in my intimate moments...
-Yeah.
-Just like, a weird, ghostly
crew member near a ladder.
-Absolutely, but, you know
let me tell you this,
and this is good
for the ladies at home.
I took this dummy home.
I let my husband go to town.
I never have to do a thing
-Do you think he knows
it's a dummy or...?
-No idea.
-No idea?
-I think he thinks
I'm in pure ecstasy.
I'm frozen in love.
-Have you tried recording
sort of sweet nothings
and put a cassette
in the dummy's head
so that he hears your voice?
-Yeah, I'm definitely
going to do a recording.
[ In Australian accent ]
"Oh, yeah, babe.
That rocks, what you doing
with your wiener."
-So that is an accent you us
in your normal,
day-to-day lovemaking?
-I think, yeah. Kind of flirty
That's me being flirty.
-Your flirty is just
a little British.
-And like, almost
dipping her toe in Australia
-You got to direct an episod
of the show this year.
-Yeah. Well, kind of.
It was a weird --
there was a false positive
and so then it was like,
"Okay, I guess I can fill in
for a couple of days.
-Oh, so they had to
sort of shut down?
-They had to half shut down,
but some people were
out of quarantine earlier,
and so I did, like, three days
of directing
myself and our crew.
And it was very weird because,
you know, there used to be
just like goofin' and toofin',
and so then I would, like,
be doing a dumb scene
and be like, "Brr-brr-brr. Cut."
And then they would be like,
"Oh, she's the director.
Cut, I guess."
-I read a story you told i
the "Chicago Tribune" recently
which was such a delight,
because --
again, my favorite stories
to hear of any performers
are the time
they bombed the hardest,
and yours happened
at Second City.
-Yeah, and, you know,
it was during this thing
that they do called "buyouts,"
which basically means
that, like,
the audience is completely
bought out by one group,
and normally that's 200 people
and they're, like, there
for a conference
and they go out after the
conference to see Second City.
But this was, like,
30 people and they were --
I don't know exactly
what their group name was,
but they were all police chief
from various cities in Texas
So it was like, an extremely
weird sample of men.
And I performed, like,
this little, quiet song
that was kind of what I base
the sketch "Joan,"
that I did with Harry Styles
where I sing a little song
to my dog --
I based it on that, and it's
like, I sing this sweet song
about a bird who's my boyfrien
and I captured him,
And truly, in the middle of it
one of the policemen stood u
and said, "This is horrible!
And he was just like,
looking me right in the eyes
And I was like,
"Uh-huh. Yes, thank you."
And then just like kept going,
in sheer terror.
-Those moments like, freeze.
Like, it's amazing
how time slows down.
-I really genuinely was like
"I've survived this
and nothing can stop me."
-That's great.
-'Cause to look a man in the eye
who hates you and continue
to be like,
"Beep-bop-ba-dee-doo-dee,"
is the ultimate,
like, "[Bleep] you, bitch.
-Well, we are all luckier
for the fact
that you overcame that moment.
-Thank you.
-And it is such a delight
to have you here,
and you're going
to stick around.
We'll be right back with mor
from Aidy Bryant.